okay like the first question you are
saying that only 27 people bought your
first one Locker a video hello how do
you stay positive when you first started
like for me like i'll have like 100
followers yeah you have some great hope
of life i read a lot of other things
where I call we should be going a lot
faster and stuff like that but like I'm
talking about like the quality of them
but I just wondering I'm patient you
know like stuff doesn't have to like her
you know the problem is Kevin Systrom
[ __ ] annihilates it sells Instagram
in two years for Billy and everybody's
like fun that's when we need to look at
what the [ __ ] is a matter of people like
right for everyone instagram there is
nine billion [ __ ] that's got it but
yeah we just all want to be that I think
that's going to happen we're never
living in a better time where you have
an opportunity to build a business
because the business opportunities now
are often predicated more than ever on
talent and time and effort you put into
it because the internet this amazing
invention that came along and all these
amazing entrepreneurs that are building
things on top of it are creating
efficiencies that don't cost us money
and they give us the time and effort in
our skill to storytelling create you
know but we just need to be patient you
know like but nothing you ask me I'm
grateful you know I mean think about how
you ask me that question I'm grateful
groups hundred but [ __ ] but take that
out of your equation and just do your
[ __ ] thanks so much appreciate haircut